à chaque fois que j'ai parlé à des
soldats qui ont été engagés dans les
combats autour de pakmouth ils m'ont dit
c'est l'enfer souvent des soldats disent
que les combats autour de batbout sont
une intensité particulière s'ils ont de
l'expérience sur d'autres parties de la
ligne de front à la comparaison avec la
bataille de bakkmouth c'est toujours
pour dire que c'est vraiment très très
difficile autour de cette ville et je
pense que les pertes des deux côtés sont
très importantes mais cela fait
maintenant plus de 5 mois que les forces
russes montent cette offensive sur
bakmouth sont toutefois arrivé à prendre
la ville je pense que ils ont pu
pénétrer certaines parties de la ville
la situation est fluide je pense que les
villages aussi qu'il revendiquent avoir
pris témoin d'une situation ou des
localités changent demain et il est
difficile de confirmer exactement qui
contrôle quoi mais ce que les Ukrainiens
disent les experts en Ukraine c'est que
il n'est pas exclu au bout de cette
bataille assis au cou la Russie arrive à
prendre le contrôle de backmouth qui est
la troisième plus grande ville
actuellement contrôlée par l'Ukraine
dans la région de Donetsk c'est possible
qu'il le prenne mais après ils n'ont pas
vraiment de stratégie pour aller plus
loin la vraie cible pour avoir une vraie
contrôle de cette partie de la région de
donuts que serait cramator ce qui est la
capitale administrative de la région de
Tonneins pendant que donuts que même est
occupé la ville de tonnes qui est occupé
par les Russes et crémator ce qui est
très bien défendu les Russes n'ont plus
la possibilité d'attaquer par le Nord
alors quelque part les ukrainiens et les
experts internationaux aussi sont
perplexes se demandent pourquoi la
Russie s'acharne tellement et de manière
si sanglante à essayer de prendre cette
ville de pakmout